Inside a ForecastFragment,
we're going to replace
the mForecastAdapter
with a simple CursorAdapter
that will work the new
database code we just added.
This is another one
we want to make sure
we're using the V4 version.
There we are.
Make sure to select
that in your list.
So you can see we have a bunch
of code that doesn't compile.
Since it's ArrayAdapter,
let's switch our ForecastAdapter out
with new simple CursorAdapter.
Now simple CursorAdapter
is pretty cool.
It allows us to map columns
within our database,
which are in our WeatherContract,
directly to widgets
that are in our list items.
So, all looks pretty good,
except that it won't quite compile.
Because, this stuff we're doing
to start the DetailActivity
isn't going to work.
So for now, let's just put this away.
We'll get back to that later.
We have something that compiles.
But we need to do something first.
If we ran it now,
we would still get nothing.
The reason why we
would still get nothing
is we aren't doing anything
in onLoadFinish.
In onLoaderReset we might
as well complete this
by doing swapCursor with null.
Our code should actually
do something now.
Let's try running it.
And it looks terrible.
What's in the database
doesn't look anything
like what's supposed
to be on the screen.
We need some formatting
and settings help.
More functions for our utility class.
Get preferred location
did look a bit lonely there, right?
To help us out, we'll add
another function to utility
that tells us if metric
is the current setting.
We'll add a simple function
to format the temperature,
and we'll add a function
to format the date.
Now interestingly enough,
what kind of date is this?
Well, we've got two options,
java.util or java.sql.
In this case we actually want java.util,
but we're missing another helper function.
We'll add a function
into WeatherContract
that converts the db date text
into an actual date object,
opposite to the other contract function.
So there we have it.
How we store the data
in the database
is entirely encapsulated
in the contract.
So, now we've got
all that cool stuff,
but how do we actually use it?
Let's go back to
our ForecastFragment.
It turns out there's
a special callback
for SimpleCursorAdapter
called viewBinder.
Set viewBinder with
a single function, SetViewValue.
So inside of SetViewValue,
we're actually going to make
really good use of those
utility functions we just saw.
First of all, we'll save off as metric.
If we're using the
temperature columns,
then we just conform out
the temperature.
Now that we've got
setViewValue,
let's put some cool stuff inside of it.
You see that we use isMetric
when we're populating
the temperature in our views,
and we pass that into our new
Utility.formatTemperature function.
So you can see that having
these column indices here
allowed us to make
this function more efficient,
and it will also help
when we move into Lesson 5.
One of the things you notice,
is that the layout height
was really, really small.
That's because it was
just wrapping content.
We can fix this by telling it
to center our content,
and by setting the minimum height
to the least preferred item height.
This will make things look
a little better as well,
a lot more like our original layout.
So let's take a quick look to see
what all of this work has done for us.
That's a little bit more like it.
Now as you can see,
we're seeing our forecast
in the original way we anticipated.
We can go to our settings
and we can switch things on demand
but now we're in that
same problem I had before,
we can't do anything
to get to the DetailActivity.
Well, I'm going to have you fix that.